plus rytas nonet spawn end à signer
nécessite à thé ou d'un an langue de
molière les multiples ne doivent pas
être multipliés sans nécessité tels est
une citation de guillaume d'ockham
philosophe logicien et théologien
anglais du 14e siècle ocam présente
ainsi un principe qu'on appelle
désormais le rasoir d'occam où le
principe de parcimonie
intuitivement dans un langage peu proche
de celui qu'on a utilisées dans cette
série ce principe affirme que les
théories plus simples sont a priori plus
crédible mais formaliser ce rasoir
d'occam est en fait loin d'être aussi
simple
notamment car la notion de simplicité
n'est pas si simple hashtag meta de meta
par exemple la théorie du multivers
cette théorie qui postule l'existence de
plusieurs univers est ce une théorie
simple en un sens on a envie de dire oui
après tout je peux expliquer cette
théorie en très peu de caractère à
savoir la théorie du multivers suppose
l'existence de plusieurs univers mais on
a un autre sens toutefois on a envie de
dire non
après tout invoquer un multi vert
revient a invoqué l'existence de
beaucoup de choses dans l'univers
certains physiciens diront ainsi que le
multivers est une solution simple pour
résoudre des problèmes difficiles comme
l'oeuf un réglage des constantes de
l'univers mais d'autres rétorqueront
qu'invoquait le multivers revient a
utilisé un marteau piqueur pour écraser
une mouche ou du moins ses postures et
une énorme complexité anthologique
c'est à dire l'existence de vraiment
beaucoup de choses alors qu'en est il le
multivers est ce une théorie simple
qu'elle crée danse a priori faute il a
signé au multi vert
pour mieux comprendre la nuit
on vient de parler il semble en fait
utile de nous tourner vers
l'algorithmique oui car l'algorithmique
nous propose une distinction rigoureuse
entre les deux notions de complexité
qu'on a esquissé la première correspond
ainsi à la longueur de la description
algorithmique de la théorie la seconde
correspond à l'espace mémoire que
nécessite l'exécution algorithmique de
la théorie prenons un autre exemple pour
comprendre à savoir le problème de
résoudre le jeu des échecs
est-ce que résoudre les échecs est
simple et bien il se trouve que les
échecs sont simples en le premier sens
mais difficile on le second en effet
l'algorithme minimax résout les échecs
et peut-être décrire en quelques
dizaines de lignes de code
dion quelques centaines s'il faut aussi
d'écrire des règles d échec si on le
compare au code de windows ou à ceux
utilisés en météorologie
c'est certainement un code très court il
existe ainsi un algorithme très court a
déclaré pour résoudre les échecs en ce
sens des échecs sont simples au passage
j'entends parfois dire que les échecs
sont simples notamment par rapport
disons au sens social car c'est un
problème dont on connaît les règles du
jeu eh bien on vient d'être plus précis
que ceux là encore ce qui rend les
échecs simple c'est surtout l'existence
d'un algorithme simple pour le résoudre
par opposition et disons au poker à huit
joueurs pour lequel les règles sont
connues il n'y a pas d'algues au rythme
simple pour déterminer la stratégie
optimale notamment parce que ça dépend
du comportement des autres joueurs
bref en un sens les échecs sont simples
car il existe un algorithme simple qui
les résout cependant l'exécution de cet
algorithme va nécessiter de garder en
mémoire de grandes quantités
d'informations comme toutes les
positions intermédiaires des échecs et
si elles sont gagnantes et perdantes ou
nulle pour les blancs et il semble qu'il
en sera inéluctablement le cas de toute
solution algorithmique aux échecs
on dit que la complexité en espace
mémoire des échecs est grande en ce sens
les échecs ne sont pas simples alors il
ya des raisons techniques pour
lesquelles le rasoir d'occam ou second
sens est en fait difficile à
complémenter qui ont à voir avec le fait
que la complexité en espace mémoire d'un
algorithme aux dépens des données sur
lesquelles il est exécuté et peut être
très très difficile d'anticiper et même
à définir a priori
a contrario la longueur de la
description d'une théorie est facile à
mesurer il suffit de compter le nombre
de lignes de code ou pour être plus
précis le nombre de caractères utilisés
dans le code source
c'est sans doute pour cette raison que
le génie informaticiens créé solomonoff
à opter pour ce critère de simplicité
pour formaliser le rasoir d'occam et
ainsi fournir une solution complète aux
fameux problème de l'induction de riom
il demeure toutefois 2
difficultés pour définir rigoureusement
l'induction de solomonoff en premier
lieu on peut se demander si la phrase la
théorie du multivers supposée existence
de plusieurs univers définit vraiment la
théorie du multivers ne faut-il pas au
moins d'écrire ses autres univers pour
répondre à cette question il est utile
de se souvenir de l'épisode précédent
la description du multivers qu'on a
donné là est en fait insuffisantes pour
décrire une théorie à la solomonoff car
cette phrase ne semblent pas permettre
d'effectuer des prédictions par exemple
au sujet de la météo qui fera demain la
description qu'on en a donné n'est pas
aux standards de seulement 9 mai la
théorie du multivers est loin d'être la
seule dans le cas de la même manière la
seconde loi de newton l'équation est
fait et gala am a beau être simple
méprise seule elle ne permet pas de
parier sur des données observable elle
est donc pas aux standards non plus de
l'induction de solomonoff idem pour des
théories comme dieu existe ou c'est la
faute aux aliens ces théories seul ne
parie pas or une théorie à la solomonoff
toi parier comme on a parlé la dernière
fois pour devenir prédictive les lois de
newton doivent s'accompagner d'une
description de l'état physique de
l'univers or sa description de l'état
physique surtout si elle est détaillée
au niveau des atomes risque fort d'être
très longue
rien comme corps contient dans les
milliards de milliards de milliards de
particules
il faudrait ainsi autour de 10 puissance
27 lignes de code pour décrire mon corps
dès lors la théorie newton plus état
physique exact de l'univers est en fait
peu crédible a priori puisque sa
description est très longue
en fait ceci explique pourquoi des
théories macroscopique comme les lois de
la thermodynamique peuvent être en un
sens plus crédible que des lois
microscopique comme la mécanique
quantique
en effet pour devenir prédictive ces
théories macroscopique peuvent souvent
être accompagnée d'une description très
partiel de l'état physique de l'univers
alors que la mécanique quantique
nécessite généralement une description
beaucoup plus précises notamment d état
physique des particules
dans ce cas la description loi plus
l'état via la thermodynamique peut être
bien plus succincte que vient la
mécanique quantique bien souvent
toutefois même en mécanique quantique
on peut se contenter d'une description
statistiques des particules plutôt que
d'une description fine typiquement on va
décrire uniquement la vitesse moyenne
des particules et pas les vitesses de
chacune des particules cette description
statistiques étant beaucoup plus
succincte
elle donnera lieu à une théorie
quantique statistiques beaucoup plus
crédible a priori de la même manière les
théories économiques ou les modèles
épidémiologistes très sophistiquée avec
des milliers de paramètres pour décrire
le comportement de chaque individu sont
en fait des théories peu crédible si on
ne dispose pas de données suffisantes
pour ajuster ces paramètres
après tout pour devenir prédictive ces
théories devront être complétés par des
choix de valeurs de ses paramètres
a contrario une simple régression
linéaire sur quelques centaines de
données empiriques ou une extrapolation
exponentielle grossière peuvent être
considérés plus crédible a priori
puisque la description du modèle
prédictif est alors extrêmement
succincte et c'est pour une raison
similaire que certaines théories du
multivers sont simples au sens de
solomonoff par exemple le multivers est
souvent invoquée pour expliquer le fait
un réglage des constantes de notre
univers ces constantes semble
particulièrement bien ajustés pour
permettre l'émergence de gallas
d'étoilés de planètes et donc pour
rendre toute vie possible dans l'univers
la théorie du multivers des fins
réglages suppose qu'il existera bien
d'autres univers descriptible par une
distribution statistique des valeurs des
constantes fondamentales dans les
différents univers
voilà une description statistiques
partielles certes mais surtout simple
est suffisante pour prédire au moins
l'existence de la vie dans au moins un
univers et pour expliquer que toute vie
observera ses valeurs de ses constantes
dans son univers au sens de solomonoff
nahla une théorie très simple qui fait
des prédictions que l'on obtient en
pratique
donc au sens de ce
la complexité d'une théorie doit être la
longueur de la description de tout ce
qui est nécessaire pour effectuer des
prédictions avec cette théorie
ok mais il reste encore quelques
problèmes en particulier les langage
usuel reste souvent minés d'ambiguïté
qui ouvre la porte à l'interprétation et
surtout à la malléabilité ainsi il
existe souvent plusieurs interprétations
différentes d'une théorie décrite dans
le langage usuel ce qui peut conduire à
différentes prédictions différentes et
il n'était alors pas clair qu'elle
prédictions sa théorie fait cette
ambiguïté du langage a mis des
millénaires à être reconnu mais comme on
l'a vu dans la salle et sur l'infini
notamment à partir du 19ème siècle
cette ambiguïté pause et a de plus en
plus de problèmes aux mathématiques et
en particulier en analyse l'ambiguïté
des mots aura ainsi conduit le pauvre
augustin lui cauchy renseigner un bon
nombre de théorèmes faux dans un cours
qui étaient pourtant alors reconnu comme
un succès mondial de rigueur
mathématique
ce n'est qu'à la fin du 19e siècle que
le langage formel fut développée par des
logiciens comme du cpp anneaux et
gottlob frigo mais non sans difficultés
après tout au tournant du siècle
bertrand russell démontra que toute
l'oeuvre de frigo était certes enfin
vidée d'ambiguïté mais elle était aussi
et surtout incohérente
bon disons qu'elle avait le don d'avoir
enlevé suffisamment d'ambiguïté pour
qu'il soit enfin possible de prouver son
incohérence
ce qui est déjà une propriété en fait
assez rare russell travaillera pendant
plus d'une décennie sur l'élaboration
d'un langage formel sans ambiguïté ni
incohérences et surtout avec des règles
de manipulation logiquement valide mais
il connut un succès mitigé
en fait les limites du langage de
russell furent démontrer inévitable par
un certain kurt gödel en 1931
ce n'est qu'en 1936 que les logiciens
alonso chuck et alan turing
développèrent enfin des langues à risque
non seulement étaient formels et sans
ambiguïté mais qui semblait aussi et
surtout universel ces langages sur le
langage du lambda calcul d'un côté et le
langage machine des machine de turing de
l'autre et leur universalité réside dans
la thèse ap les thèses de church turing
selon laquelle chacun de ces langages
pouvait exprimer toutes les théories
exécutable dans notre univers
malheureusement le lambda calcul de
chuck et le langage machine de turing
demeurent tous deux très difficile à
comprendre et à utiliser pour le commun
des mortels
et même pour le commun des génie
scientifique mais au fil des décennies
des progrès spectaculaires ont été faits
dans l'élaboration de langage formel
turing complet et compréhensible si bien
que désormais certains de ces langages
sont utilisées par des millions
d'humains sur terre et sont même
enseigné à l'école c'est langage formel
et universel on les appelle aussi des
langages de programmation turing complet
et des langages comme basique c++ java
script trust et python en sont des
exemples
en fait le clip est à nos frigos church
et turing serait sans doute émerveillé
par la prépondérance de tel langage
désormais qu'ils sont ainsi parlé plus
tôt écrit par des millions d'humains sur
terre
c'est plus que par exemple le breton
désolé les bretons et ses langages sont
bien sans ambiguïté puisque même une
machine saura comment les interpréter
c'est sans doute ce qui a convaincu
solomonoff de définir la complexité
d'une théorie par la longueur de sa
description dans un langage de
programmation turing complet
on a maintenant tout ce qu'il faut
lisez le rasoir d'occam si on considère
un langage elle il suffit maintenant de
considérer que la probabilité à priori
d'une théorie à la somme 9 et
exponentiellement faible en la longueur
de sa description
alors pour des raisons techniques dont
on a parlé dans l'épisode 29
il se trouve que pour des machine de
turing universelle en langage binaire
les particulièrement naturel de
considérer que la crédence a priori
d'une théorie t descriptible en nba est
inversement proportionnelle à de
puissants scène où la constante est
rajustée de sorte que la somme des
probabilités de toutes les théories à la
salle olof a priori est égal à 1 on
obtient ainsi la priory de seulement 9
alors désolé pour le charabia technique
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que toute
cette construction est en fait
extrêmement naturelle et conduit à
définir un a priori parfaitement
conforme au rasoir d'occam a priori les
théories plus simple à décrire son
exponentiellement plus crédible mieux
encore l'a priori de solomonoff convient
de définir a aussi le bon goût d'être
universel dans le sens où il assigne une
crédence strictement positive à toutes
les théories à la soul man of aucune
théorie néo dogmatiquement rejetée par
l'induction de solomonoff aucune ne
manque à l'appel
il reste une fois 1
problème tout la construction de somme 9
dépend du langage de programmation
utilisé en effet certaines idées simples
a exprimé dans certains langages semble
nécessairement laborieuse a exprimé dans
d'autres mais alors quel langage de
programmation utiliser et bien à ce
sujet je vous invite à lire un extrait
écrit par le m pendant longtemps j'ai eu
l'impression que la dépendance de
l'induction de solomonoff ans le langage
de programmation de référence était une
faille sérieuse du concept et j'ai
cherché un langage universel
objectif libérer de tout arbitraire dû à
un choix particulier de langage quand
j'ai pensé avoir enfin trouvé un langage
de la sorte je me suis rendu compte que
je n'en voulais pas vraiment je n'en
voyais aucune utilité
notez que la citation originale parle de
machines et pas de langage car
solomonoff utilise de formalisme de
turing est donc impérativement le
langage considérer est le langage
machine de la machine de turing
universel de référence mais donc
pourquoi n'y at il pas de quoi être
préoccupé par la dépendance du rasoir
d'occam en le langage de référence le
choix du langage de référence ne fait-il
pas une grande différence est alors oui
ça fait une différence
mais non ça ne fait pas une grosse
différence comme solomonoff l'a démontré
en 1960 et sa démonstration s'appuie sur
l'existence de traducteurs entre langage
turing complet démontré par tuerie en
1936 plus précisément pour tous les
langages turine complet elle et m
il existe un code s'est appelée
compilateur pour traduire le langage
elle dans le langage m
ainsi pour toute théorie t on peut
prendre une description t elle de la
théorie t écrite dans le langage l on
peut ensuite fournir cela au compilateur
c
le compilateur c va alors traduit rtl en
un texte tm dans le langage m
il va ensuite exécuté le texte tn mais
alors le texte ctl est un texte dans le
langage n qui est équivalent à t elle
est créée dans le langage elle donc pour
tout texte t elle dans le langage elle
il existe un texte de longueur longueur
de ctl qui est égal à longueur de 7 plus
à longueur d t elle
dans le langage m qui décrit la même
chose que le texte t elle appelons
maintenant qu'à elle de thé la plus
courte description de la théorie tu es
dans le langage elle
et considérant que tu es l s est plus
courte description en appliquant le
principe de compilation que l'on vient
de voir n'obtient ainsi un texte qui
décrit la théorie tu es dans le langage
n et dont la longueur est la longueur de
ctl qui est égale à la longueur de ses
puces à longueur de t elle est égale à
kayes doté à savoir la plus courte
description de la théorie tu es dans le
langage elle met donc la plus courte
langage
m et forcément plus courte que ce qu'on
a obtenu en appliquant le compilateur a
t elle
ce qui nous donne l'inégalité km2 t est
inférieur ou égal à kl2 tu es plus la
longueur du compilateur et de façon
remarquable cette inégalité est vrai
quelle que soit la théorie ou dit
autrement la dépendance du rasoir
d'occam au langage utilisé est au plus
la longueur du compilateur l 2 c or il
existe généralement des compilateurs
assez court pour des langages classiques
disent on peut être de l'ordre du ko
pour ses puces plus où j'avais et même
des compilateurs bien plus concis entre
les machine de turing universelle les
plus élémentaires
du coup elles ne sont de plus courte
longueur de descriptions de théorie est
quasiment indépendante du langage
utilisé cette mesure de complexité cas
elle dotée pour le langage elle est
souvent appelée la complexité de
kolmogorov de la théorie tu es dans le
langage elle mais à titre personnel je
préfère l'appeler la complexité de
solomonoff puisque kolmogorov qui a
introduit cette notion en 1963 à
lui-même reconnu que ce l'aumône of
l'avait précédée dans la définition et
études de ce terme
et d'ailleurs ironie de l'histoire en
2003 selon l'ofs a reçu le prix
kolmogorov pour son invention de la
complexité de kolmogorov entre autres vu
tout le prestige qui a déjà comme le
goff qui a notamment posé les axiomes
des probabilités
décidément entre turing shouting martin
9 et d'autre lui aussi était enfant sur
les probabilités et l'algorithmique
prévu le prestige qui a déjà comme le
core of je pense que ça ne serait pas
trop heurter son héritage que de
renommer sa définition de la complexité
sous le nom de complexité de solomonoff
bref la complexité de solomon of dépend
du langage mais elle ne dépend pas trop
du langage si bien considérer qu'il
s'agit d'une mesure assez fondamental en
tout cas si l'on considère des théories
dont la complicité de saumoneaux fait de
l'ordre du million
le choix du langage de référence
importera finalement assez peu surtout
sachant le théorème d'incomplétude de
solomonoff et ça
on en parle dans la prochaine vidéo
alors pour vous
vidéo je vais contester un peu cette
façon usuel de présenter l'induction de
sylob 9 comme étant une formalisation du
rasoir d'occam en fait le rasoir d'occam
n'est pas vraiment un postulat
nécessaires aux résultats de solomonoff
il s'agit même davantage en quelque
sorte d'une conséquence du formalisme de
saumoneaux et même en fait d'une
conséquence du bas et ziani sme je
m'explique
considérons des théories exprimable dans
un langage données qui peut être même
plus générale qu'un langage de
programmation turing complet certaines
théories seront exprimable en mille
caractères d'autres en 1 millions de
caractères et ainsi de suite pour tous
nombre n de caractère implanté m
l'ensemble des théories dont la plus
courte description tien an men caractère
a priori n'est pas nécessaire de donner
plus de créer dans sa paix n quand elle
prend des valeurs faibles
a priori une envie de dire qu'on n'est
pas obligé d'invoquer le rasoir d'occam
cependant pour pouvoir appliquer le
belize à nice mme il faut absolument que
la somme des crédences a priori de
toutes les théories soit égal à 1
et ça c'est un pic que la crédence des
tories a un caractère plus la crédence
des théories a deux caractères plus
sacré dans des théories à trois
caractères et ainsi de suite jusqu'à
l'infini
c'est à dire p2 t1 plus paix doté de
puces p2 t3 plus p2 t4 est ainsi de
suite
ça ça doit être égal à 1 on alors une
somme d'une infinité de nombre positif
qui prend une valeur fini d'après la
théorie des séries infinie ceci ne peut
arriver que si la probabilité de
l'ensemble tnt théorie am caractère tend
vers zéro
autrement dit de baïse à nice mme
implique que les théories avec trop de
caractère finissent nécessairement par
devenir négligeable et de façon
remarquable cette version du rasoir
d'occam n'est ainsi pas un postulat du
bail à nice mme il s'agit d'un théorème
du bail à nice mme ce théorème de cannes
dit que la crédence a priori de théorie
trop longue et négligeable en fait pour
les longues et ardues ring complet au
moins on peut même affirmer quelque
chose de plus fort que cela comme le
nombre de théories am caractère est
exponentielle en scène
sacré danse a priori sera en moyenne
exponentiellement faible entraîne les
théories plus longue ne sont pas justes
moins crédible elles sont même a priori
exponentiellement moins crédible et là
encore il ne s'agit pas d'un principe
philosophique qu'il nous faut
dogmatiquement accepté pour tous
bayésiens il s'agit d'un
théorème auquel les lois des
probabilités le contraint à obéir
tel fut l'une des plus puissantes et
découvertes que j'ai eu le bonheur de
faire avant même de suivre les pas de
somme 9 lors de mon fantastique périple
bayésiens mais la plus grande de toutes
les jouissances au cours de ce périple
inoubliable qui se poursuit encore ça
restera assurément et de loin ma
découverte des théorèmes de complétude
et d'incomplétude de solomonoff et je
trépigne d'impatience car on va
justement enfin en parler la prochaine
fois